weddy are we going to Bonnie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's no denying it woody is the toy
every kid deserves but this cowboy is at
a crossroads and he's got a choice to
make or retire with his one and only
little bo-peep well you probably already
know the answer to that so let's jump
right in and explore the Toy Story 4 and
David Bonney
made a friend in class the last thing
porky wants is to be a toy he wants to
be a disposable sport he loves trash
cans and will do just about anything to
get thrown out but now that woody knows
he's no longer the favorite toy he'll
stop at nothing to keep for ki and
Bonnie's toy collection but keeping an
eye on for ki proves to be pretty much
impossible and sooner than later an evil
doll named Gabby Gabby and her
terrifying ventriloquist henchman
the Bensons capture for ki and hold him
hostage in exchange for for ki all Gabby
Gabby wants is Woody's voice box but at
first woody refuses to give it to her he
tries to rescue for ki from the antique
shop again and again but with no avail
once what he realizes that time is
running out he makes the ultimate
sacrifice and gives Gabby Gabby exactly
what she wants losing his voice box
makes him a lot less valuable but that
doesn't stop him after all for ki is the
most important toy in Bonnie's
collection right now and she'll be
devastated if she loses him you're
Bonnie's toy you are going to help
create happy memories that will last for
the rest of her life
Gabby Gabby and the Bensons are super
scary they're bigger and stronger than
everyone else and they know it too but
it turns out that Gabby isn't as bad as
she seems and after hearing her
backstory we sort of felt bad for her
all Gabby wants is what Woody's always
had a loving kid but since she was made
with a defect she was never loved
Gabby's convinced that if she fixes her
defective Voicebox a little girl named
harmony will want to take her home and
love her unconditionally but in the end
she turns out to be wrong harmony wants
nothing to do with her voice box and all
this devastating moment it's a total
tearjerker seen how sad gabby gabby was
made woody want to help her that's just
the kind of cowboy he is but something
magical happens on their way back to
Bonnie
Gabby sees a lost and crying child at
the carnival and decides to go with her
this
key moment couldn't have been any more
perfect the villain of the story gets
the happy ending she always dreamed of
and so does the rest of the gang Oh
Sheriff would he always come in to the
rescue if there's one thing Bo Peep
knows about pudding it's that he always
puts his kids needs before his own
that's why all those years ago would he
chose to stay with Andi instead of Bo
but this time around something is
different and woody knows it unlike
before woody isn't his kid's favorite
toy Tech Bonnie probably wouldn't even
notice if he went missing so instead of
going back to the RV what he chooses to
become a lost toy with Bo Peep and his
new friends but before he can go he
needs to make sure that Bonnie still has
a sheriff in town so he gives Jessie his
gold star and says goodbye to his toy
family but saying goodbye doesn't mean
that the story is over in fact a new
chapter in Woody's life has just begun
since toys are the happiest when they're
with children woody and his gang of lost
toys decide to travel with the carnival
they go from town to town and help toys
finds brand new homes ducky and bunny
spent years tied to a gaming station at
a carnival I don't care which Cabbage
Patch you're from gave me back my
viewmaster before I knock the dimples
off your face they were forced to watch
as kids continuously failed to hit the
target and bring home a toy but thanks
to woody and his friends more kids are
winning toys than ever before
ducky bunny Bo duck and woody rigged the
carnival game to make sure that every
single kid wins a prize it involves a
little cheating but hey it's for a good
cause
woody is happier than ever and he
finally has a new purpose in life if
you're wondering what happens to buzz
Jesse and the rest of the gang well it's
all happy endings from here on out as
the newly appointed sheriff and favorite
toy
jesse is now in charge of the group Kian
bazaar great leaders and if they ever
find themselves in a pickle they can
always look up at the stars and ask what
would would he do thankfully woody
taught buzz to listen to his inner voice
before he left so everything should turn
out fine we catch a glimpse of the
future during the post-credit scene
that's when we find out that forky won't
be the only anxious toy you tinsel for
too much longer on Bonnie's first day of
first grade she comes home with a brand
new toy this utensil is everything for
ki could ever want in a plastic knife we
mean did you see those freckles
for ki falls in love in no time
and promises to show who we can only
assume is named knifey what it means to
be a toy but if there's one post-credit
scene that has its collecting our jaws
off the ground it's the one that stars
duckie and bunny it's no secret that
these toys have a wild imagination you
are I don't care bear we mean they did
spend a few years tied to the back of a
carnival kiosk so it's to be expected
but we never thought that these two
cuddly looking flushed animals could be
so terrifying in the bonus scene we see
duckie and bunny attack the kiosk worker
they chase him around and start getting
bigger and bigger then out of nowhere
they start shooting laser beams out of
their eyes these toys are seriously
crazy luckily this team turned out to be
a daydream or a day nightmare as we like
to call it we absolutely loved Toy Story
4 it was a happy ending on all fronts
but does this mean that the Toy Story
franchise is coming to an end or should
we expect to hear about Toy Story 5 in a
couple of years what does you guys think
about the movie let us know in the
comments below and be sure to tell us if
you think Toy Story 5 is in the works
huh for more videos about your favorite
movies TV shows and cartoons subscribe
to the things and be sure to give this
video a big thumbs up while you're at it
we'll see you next time to infinity and
beyond
[Music]